you and i have something in common and
that i feel like we're both obsessed
with billy eilish
yes ma'am oh i love billy eilish i mean
you instagrammed about her comments
on coronavirus you defended her against
the trolls of the internet yeah body
shaming her
why did you kind of feel compelled to do
that
you know it's just so
dumb that anyone i mean any any
woman in the spotlight is already under
a tremendous amount of pressure i mean
the internet is gross
and awful and i hate it um but she
especially for some reason i don't know
if it's because
she's so young and it just feels so
inappropriate
for anyone to comment on any young
person's body
ever it's just gross it's gross man i
think people really forget themselves
because the internet is this
wall that they can hide behind um but i
think
i think i just felt personally
affronted by it because i mean she's a
beautiful young girl who is making
unbelievable
like earth-changing art you know she's
and she's
she's doing this with her brother like
on their own i mean she's an amazing
like
artist and i just it made me so furious
you know it's such a dumb thing for
people to talk about
and i know i mentioned in like my my
tweet or whatever that i looked just
like i mean i
looked exactly like that when i was her
age and it's just
i had a horrible time because i think
things have
improved in terms of um body image for
girls and boys like
and everybody i think things are much
more um
inclusive now but when i was growing up
i mean it was not like that
so i i faced a lot of that a lot
well thank you it's it you made me the
jerk i am today um you know
and uh anytime i see something like that
i just
i don't know something about this
specifically made me really angry and i
just thought it was gross and i
said something um you know
i don't know if it will make a
difference to anyone but i hope people
know that
like people are in their corner and and
that stuff's not okay
did she uh reach out afterwards or did i
no no
okay i
to me it's just like this young artist
is being attacked for a dumb reason and
it's gross
[Music]
let's talk about this movie
friendsgiving it was so
funny it was very relatable but not
necessarily your
your feel good holiday
how would you kind of describe it well
like you said it's not your typical
thanksgiving film it's actually great
because there aren't many thanksgiving
movies i personally really
you know speaking of holidays i love the
theme movie it's like my favorite thing
ever
um you can steal my pumpkins like i you
know i really love celebrating that
stuff
my character abby her family is back in
jersey and she's in la and
all she wants is to spend the day with
her best friend moping about her breakup
and just
eat a bunch of snacks and go to sleep
early that's all she wants
um yeah which is very relatable by the
way
and then her best friend who's going
through a divorce is like you know what
forget it i want
i know we said we were going to do this
but i want to be surrounded by people so
this is what happens when two friends
who are both heartbroken want to do one
day very differently
i think this thing that people are going
to be talking about is the scene
uh where you make out with aisha tyler
yes
i make out with aisha tyler i guess i
forgot to mention that
up front um it happened i actually i
have to
say it was really fun
i enjoyed it much more than when i have
to make atlas
um male actors i don't know why
what yeah well i was gonna say why you
don't know i think because i
well i'm just a weird i don't know
there's something about a like a
a kissing or a love scene that's
always a little uncomfortable there's no
way around it i mean it really depends
on your relationship with the other
actor man or
our lady i mean but aisha like i love
her so much and we became
so close so quickly so it was just kind
of like oh yeah
yeah like i'm kissing my friend i don't
care i've i've kissed
uh i kissed bad bears and two bro girls
and it was just literally
like kissing my hand like it was it felt
so
easy i don't know what this says about
me but i
i just have an easier time with females
though yeah especially when there's like
people filming you and it's so
uncomfortable no matter what
have you ever had any awkward stories
bringing a significant other to
a thanksgiving or a holiday or has
someone else in your family
i remember when an ex-boyfriend of mine
showed up to trick-or-treat at my
parents house
and i was there yeah we broke it up
i mean it's fine i don't really have any
animosity with any of my
exes at all so it was but at the time it
was just like why
are you here why are you here it was
just
like my dad was like hey look who's here
i was like
what you know was this an adult like why
was he an adult
yeah an adult um
why not you know um so that was
interesting
yeah that's funny something important
that we have to discuss is the election
that's coming up on tuesday
you've been very vocal about it you also
tweeted about wanting your
new zealand citizenship
that you were willing to be part of a
loveless marriage if that would get you
the new zealand citizenship so just
wondering if you had any offers
um shockingly i have had some um
and i quickly realized it was not a
great seeming
thing to do but i think you know in the
heat of the moment of
the the situation with covid in the
states i'm just
i'm so saddened by the situation we're
in here
and versus you know some place like new
zealand that has
gotten it under control in a pretty
short amount of time and it's just
you know in my saddest times i'm just
like why can't we
do this like why can't we do this it's
so unfair to everybody so that's
where that came from okay but
you know we're just i'm just gonna tough
it out
and if i were to fall in love with this
new zealand person
yeah you know maybe but probably
probably i'll just stay where i'm at i
think what people like
about you and like why we connect to you
so much as a because you're an amazing
actress and you're so funny but also
because
on social media you're very much
yourself
it's true is there anything that you are
hesitant
to ever share about yourself um
i don't share most things um
and it's not because i i have any
secrets or anything but it's just that i
have found that when i've shared
personal like very personal things
you know like who i'm dating or whatever
it is like it's
it kind of gets it kind of feels icky
um it kind it just there's there's
something about
letting a huge amount of people into
your life that
that um it just depends on your
personality some people
have no issue and are kind of an open
book and i'm i'm just
i've just learned over the years it's
just not it doesn't feel good
for me um so yeah i don't really sure
anything um except my unfiltered um
opinions that sometimes will probably
get me in trouble with somebody um but
but any any detail about my personal
life like
i've now kept to myself just because it
just doesn't feel
[Music]
good